it exploded all over Twitter kids in
megawhatts taunting a Native American
man well not so fast
soon after other tape surfaced where it
appears the teens were doing cheers when
approached by the drummer who beat the
instrument in their faces
this was after different activists had
approached and harassed the teens so
with more info this news story seems
different than the old story how did
this happen well first the media
embraced this story because that's what
we do we can't resist being first and it
provided or can't resist being second
anyway and the media provided who has
provided their favorite villain the red
cap yep because for the press
you can't spell hate without hat and the
media I came up with that the media knew
this story also would distract from the
BuzzFeed mess so it was a nice break
from their own humiliations
I saw the story unfold and trusting my
own eyes I saw obnoxious teens my
chaperone instinct kicked in meaning if
I'm critiquing libs all day
I should also police my own side as well
by the way isn't that the big question
here where were the chaperones I always
had them when I was in high school I
deserved them anyway I said the kids
should apologize but maybe it should be
me for jumping the gun however I do know
this this story has changed once and
it's gonna change again which is why
it's up to us and to me not to take the
bait when we're bored or possibly
drinking on a Saturday afternoon I said
it before always be skeptical nobody
knows where a story goes that's great
advice I gave next time I'll take it
all right I requested for you Dana yeah
big story today or one of the big
stories today is all of the celebrities
and media types are ripping off they're
taking down their Twitter in which they
were bashing these kids
I left mine up because I feel that if
you make as your principled well I think
that you should I think that's I think
taking something down if you think it's
wrong now if the tweet in danger
somebody you should take it down but I
think you should always leave your
footprints up right until you take it
all away right I mean I in some ways you
know how like we complain that in the
media like something will happen and
then there's a correction
yes but the correction only gets a tenth
of the attention as the original article
so I could see where you might want to
take it down but it does raise a very
interesting question but they're trying
to erase it so that you know like this
whole fight in Europe do you have a
right to be forgotten mm-hmm but you
well one thing you have a right to do is
you don't have to tweet yeah you
actually don't have to do it but you
should as an adult in particular have to
own what you say and if you got it wrong
you then you just add like so I got it
wrong yeah I'm trying to get some
attention I guess on that if that was
the concern yeah Jesse the school may
sue for slander I also saw that on
Twitter but I think it might I think it
sounds like they they have do they have
a case suing for slander stuff it's a
pretty high bar I mean the president
wants to sue everybody for slander it
has he been successful probably not but
there's one of your better monologues
correct oh would you do differently this
time a little different okay okay here's
my tank that was the great incident
story became a controversy because the
guy smoked that's a smoker
I'd like to defend smirking you that you
were so right smirking is not a hate
crime yeah smirking I do when I'm either
amused or content or calm and sometimes
it's used to defuse a situation because
it's kind of a non-violent thing but
people hate being smoked at and I've
often been said that I have the most
punchable face on television I've even
said that to you people say people say
that to me on Twitter all the time and
when I was looking at this story I saw
that people are saying this kid
the most punchable face besides Jessie
water and for some reason smirking
elicits this reaction but bottom line
Gregg the black Hebrew Israelites
they're not getting any attention here
because they are the ones they didn't
stated this entire thing and I've run to
these people in the streets there are
some of the most racist hateful people
you will ever encounter in your whole
life and I understand why these kids
were chanting and trying to create a
counter protest and reactions I don't
know that I think they were chanting
along with the Native Americans but do
that to Jesse's point about this group I
used to see them in Times Square all the
time they're the worst
yeah what is there I don't know that
much about them what is there really
what is their religion what is their if
you do well the Bible I mean basically
what they're saying is that you know
they're the real Israelites okay and
that they're the real people who are the
chosen ones oh my god not Jewish people
and all the rest and they have all sorts
of sort of elaborate mythology ideology
you know religious theory yeah it puts
them at the center of the universe and
they do say hateful things and they can
be threatening but what you heard here
initially was that the Native American
elder said there are only four of the
Israelites and there was a big group of
kids in the maggots and all the rest and
he thought they were attacking because
the the Israelites were saying the
offensive things and the kids were
starting to come back and screaming at
them and he I said to saw them laughing
and well no chanting or whatever the
high school channels but they never they
never said build the wall or whatever I
don't know about that I don't know but
they come but so he intervenes according
to him what he told reporters was he
intervened to stop the high school kids
from attacking what he described as
their prey these four black guys right
but then of course we see subsequent
eight may be not the case but I will say
that what strikes me is that both the
Roman Catholic High School and the
diocese both initially apologized based
on what we first saw right yep yeah I
agree and I thought that they should
Apollo because what I saw the just the
initial stuff and I thought my first
thing though is I just didn't see any
adults there yeah now we have to Whitney
what we have to worry about is what
happens to
this kid this kid it's other students
whose faces everywhere and is getting
death threats because that's what
happened which is crazy and he's saying
is he and his family are getting death
threats you know I watched two hours
plus of this video from three different
angles and I did find it fascinating
that the only thing people were talking
about this kids smirk and they were
talking about the chanting and you could
argue you could say this is a bunch of
you know high school boys and their
parents maybe need to have a
conversation with them about when you're
in a chaotic or antagonistic situation
just walk away
don't stand there don't stare somebody
down you can say that but what did the
kids so far from what we know what did
they actually do there's no assault here
what you do have though is the black
Hebrew Israelites shouting anti-gay
slurs racist slurs they call them
blue-eyed demons yes literally
demonization young Klansmen they call
them school shooters and they do that
before and after the entrance of Nathan
Phillips so what it looks like is a
chaotic scene and I watched it from
every angle and I didn't I didn't see
Nathan Phillips get surrounded by them
and in a menacing way I saw him walk
right into the scene so I think in the
age of Twitter it's hard because you see
the story you're right you want to jump
you want to comment but I was surprised
to see how many people and I actually I
have to commend some reporters there
were some reporters on other networks
that jumped to conclusions and walked it
back and said listen I'm sorry I
shouldn't have done that because when
you watch the whole video it's so clear
that these kids were being antagonized
how they responded you could say wasn't
mature I don't expect a high school
teenager to be mature and maybe they did
say some crazy stuff that's gonna get
unleashed but as of now the amount of
coverage that they got for a rude
expression versus what those black
Israelites said is astonishing tip well
I think if we learned anything there's a
future Jesse Watters out there I'll get
knocked out yes and white cover that
hair all right look at that thing it's
just growing man